you're on thank you Nick abroad now am I
on yeah you got it okay thank God said
greetings and salutations welcome back
to gamespot cross kind of fighting my
name is Colin this is nick and we're
joined by the Alustriel us treas Warren
laning of Ottawa Fame thanks for having
day without anger to see a greater come
away much alright so here's the thing
Nick yes we had Lauren landing at our
apartment I recall uh for the kind of
funny HQ yes and I was in Iceland I
think for some reason yeah oh yeah you
weren't there yeah oh you missed out I
know and this you miss that I came back
he Greg's like you and Lauren landing oh
my god would have been talking each
other's videos that the problem is we're
live on on camera we're beaming to the
masses via the interweb right I don't
think Lauren can say half the stuff we
talked about during uh mostly cuz it's a
lot he I mean this man the depth of his
knowledge yeah is fast no there's no
doubt about and you know Warren you're
known as you know you've been in this
industry a long time you have you're a
visionary you have great opinions and
interesting opinions in your outspoken
well thank you yeah it's a very nice way
to put it no I don't so I mean and and
he told me he's like oh all the ball the
Bourbon all the brown liquors yours in
the house yeah and then he was like
sorry some of its missing yeah yes soon
it was okay at all I any you could give
up a whole bottle yeah um what do you
think of the show so Marvins day 3 i'm
curious what you're seeing when i made
about to me in the last couple years III
is only been getting a lot more
interesting and because what are we
seeing you know for a long time all
we're seeing is bigger bigger bigger
bigger bigger now we're seeing you know
we're just looking at galaxy right yeah
right there right next to with no man's
guy next to no man's guy next to 100
million dollar title there's call of
duty right so we weren't seeing that for
years ago but we're seeing that more and
more now we're seeing no man Scott
another small indie group with a big
idea and all sudden becoming something
big and we hope they really nail it you
know but to see the diversity is what's
exciting now we have the whole other
frontier right vr AR this is anyone
who's really had a good sample knows
game changer right here's we've been
living with the screen and now we're
starting to experience inside the screen
and we know
really really powerful stuff coming lots
of things to learn lots of confusion but
seeing that in the diversity you know
who are we seeing here for the first
time I've seen it uh yeah what's
happening Brian Brian Fargo yeah right
and for the first time we're seeing
Facebook's got boots here you know like
everyone's trying to get into the
industry which is fabulous and we have
all these competing networks and what
does that do creates more opportunity
for more younger people or ambitious
smaller teams to create new IP and offer
to network some diversity something
because all these networks that are now
competing is gonna be all the answer TV
manufacturers going to be competing
against one another they all need
special offerings that's opportunity for
content creators that's exciting and
right now this show this is the widest
range of games ever displayed at the
show on the widest ranges of devices
with the most revolutionary devices all
those things present here so pretty
exciting pretty big win you brought up
VR and I'm interested in and you know a
more like kind of a more in-depth
opinion on VR because I agree we are
something that everyone seems skeptical
of until they use it yeah I was
certainly one of those people as people
are tired of hearing the story a couple
years ago when i played oculus for the
first time here at e3 and played eval
curry I was blown away and it was the
only demo on my 93 said I ever asked to
play again yeah there because it was so
revolutionary do you think VR is really
the true game changer and are you
worried about how do you show it to
someone because you can't until they put
on that head that was interesting you
know a number of people ask me they said
that at the sony press event you know
why didn't they show more VR a go
because you can't really show great
video that's my assumption they didn't
tell me but I'm just going well it's
obvious it doesn't you don't get it if
you're looking at the 20th century flat
screen experience right so you do have
to be there but once you're there you
know it's over right scale is real like
in just it just take a very simple
concept you're going to confront a 200
foot monster now in filmmaking I need to
put someone small in front of that get
on the right camera to give a sense of
scale because you don't have a sense
scale even with a big movie screen
you've got to put references in there
from real world now you don't have the
screen your past the screen you're in
the world
now a 50 65 foot tyrannosaurs walking
towards you well if you want to look at
his head you're up there and you want to
look at his feet you down there and
scale is real yeah you stand on the edge
of the building you look over the clip
over the edge if you've got a fear of
heights you're you're frozen man you
know when I did that demo the valve demo
were you standing in the in the
steampunk city on the edge of it on the
edge of the building 40 stories up
looking down at the street and the
slightest millimeter waiver back and
forth like oh my god or I'm in the
Morpheus demo where the shark tank the
shark cage and a great white is swimming
by and I see the little flub of his fat
moving and it's it is this big going by
scale is real that's a real game-changer
so you just think about the principles
of game design as we know them throw
most of them out leave them out off in a
back table they're not going to apply in
this new space the simple act of walking
up to an edge of a building can be a
major massive confrontational sort of
sort of rotating block for you as a
gamer whereas in it behind the screen it
was like well I got to get over that
thing right now it's like oh my god this
is terrifying but just do you guys feel
like VR though is this is this is it
it's actually going to happen it's gonna
catch on it's not a gimmick it's not a
motion it's not 3d this is an actual
thing that we're going to be living with
now as gamers for the restaurant is no
doubt you think now yeah because when I
first saw it i mean we hearken back to
the 80s and the early 90s when you know
TV manufacturers you know we just saw
the 3d revolution how to come and go
again yeah with TVs now what we really
saw there was TV manufacturers and film
studios trying to figure out how do we
sell how do we get people back into the
theater right and how do we how do we
keep the theaters alive how do we sell
more TVs now that everyone has their big
screen HD what are we going to sell them
well what about 3d and that's what
really drove it it wasn't the audience
saying we want 3d it was driven by there
are basically big corporations they need
growth they need to have people you know
it's like fashion right we need to get
you to buy new clothes before your old
ones wore out because that's how we
survive so when you look at that on the
screen space that's what brought 3d TVs
that's what made 3d movies give you an
example I was just at a place called
Kerner elected it used to be called
Kerner electric it's the old ivy ilm up
san rafael gosh i watched mad max there
in their theater a couple weeks ago all
visual effects guys all ILM guys all
gray-haired season visual effects many
cabin boy awards these are guys that do
the best 3d right and he's and the guy
presenting to us said I'm you know we
fortunately got this in 3d for you guys
to watch and it's great how many of you
prefer the 3d over the 2d not one hand
though everyone who even makes them is
like just show me a beautiful film map I
don't want the headset yeah ask the kids
do you want to go see the 3d film the
first few times they did it's fading so
we see that didn't drive what's driving
VR it wasn't that the audience said I
really wanted it wasn't said the
industry said well we got to figure out
how to sell more headsets and so VR is
the answer what happened was people
started dabbling it and other people
started feeling it and that everyone
went whoa from Mark Zuckerberg to you
know across the board when they got in
there when you're Silicon Valley VCS get
in there and they go oh my god everyone
realizes it's a game changer now the big
question is when is it viable that's my
question yeah I don't know yeah I don't
know I think it's going to take a while
I think it's so powerful I think we're
going to have lots of little fuzzy
issues we're going to have lots of fizzy
problems we're going to have youtube
visit videos of frat boys saying drink
those two six-packs and then beat that
level right and we're gonna see
projectile vom that happens that's our
weekend yeah this part we're going to
see all these problems the other thing
is a are right its beginning and it's
not going to go away so that they're the
real difference is VR is completely
submersible alternate reality and you
know when you're there and you're
engaged this one doesn't exist right so
that means it has to be a very safe
environment that means it's not as
mobile as we would like to think it
could be then we have AR which is all
about mobility where Yelp and Google
Maps and is going to be something where
we walk down the street and we're
watching a just say i want to see pizza
place that have stores and people are
going to have a 200-foot pizza in
hologram flipping a Brazilian watching
minority report in real life you might
not give you Austin saying
eat my pizza here and I'm like so lucky
your damn pizza until I want to eat your
damn pizza exactly you know and is that
hollow lens or is that magically poor
which ones are going to win which is
going to be the big headsets winning in
VR not sure I think you know Sony
clearly right they got the trust of the
the plastic to the manufacturer us to
the stores the trucks are already
delivering games Playstations to the
stores that are going to sell the VR
right they already got the network PSN
it's going to sell the games that work
with the VR who has the most well
greased Avenue into being successful at
vr I think it's Sony right that's that's
who I think we're going to be a clear
winner who else is winning I'm not
exactly sure but I doubt Sony's not
gonna win you know and just you did you
get a chance to see the halal and stuff
oh yeah the hollow lens no and I want to
yeah and here it's ridiculous I haven't
got a head change we tried to go over
there yesterday and got shut down
because Kanye West was in the building
and low well we're American royalty I'm
no calling I'm know Kanye apparel yeah
yes my wife tells me all the time
apparently apparently it's amazing and
that's technology to that is what you're
talking about right where it's not that
fully immersive experience the truck is
augmenting reality in front of you and
if it can make me feel like Tony Stark
i'm in i might be in you know we're not
even touching on all the you know the
porn possibilities i know it's gonna be
it's gonna be no i mean feel free to
touch on foreign because that's how we
pay well let me tell you this i just
heard a pitch last night where guy was
saying look is a he was selling it to
another guy so I'm reinterpreting sir
but the essence was this I've been with
a lot of women but I've only felt with
true love from three but in VR I found
the fourth you know what he's describing
like after this happened and after that
happened she looked at my eyes and said
I love you and he goes that I was I felt
what I felt the only three times
everything like you listen to a man's
experience right and and and it was in
the context of a theoretical discussion
about whether or not it's gonna happen
what goes and what he was saying is when
you feel that you don't care yeah it's
like those real deal with real to you
and you're never going to feel that on a
flat screen right right and so in the
landscape of where uh thank you thanks
mr. Miller thank you you did a great job
today
it's got promise sorry for the
interruption imagine in a landscape of
where you know back in the 90s if you
had a pizza place and you didn't have a
website you were on your way to the
graveyard right right the future is
you're going to need just like we needed
websites for every business businesses
are going to need a are possibilities
where virtual real estate is going to
become real the way that high-rises
bought air rights in New York to build
over schools that didn't want to be torn
down right this is going to happen ever
you walk down the street you're going to
be like I want to see wherever coffees
on sale and I want to run my filters the
way I would through a search except
that's going to be coming at me in life
as I walk down the street i'll be
walking down what looks like a boring
street i switch my channel to see the
yelp ads that are running there and i'll
be seeing you know 50-foot dinosaurs
over here at the tourist or what is it
do you think this means that Apple is
going to make glasses one day with
they're gonna make sunglasses or some
sort of glass like screw the watch i
want i think that is inevitable origin
contact lenses you think contact like
this eMeter is contact lenses with chips
and air beaming you know it's like who
knows where this goes right technology
is getting smaller nano computing's
right nano you know quantum computers
like right on threshold when that
happens this is you know I think the
headsets we're looking at today very
interesting but in 10 years from now
they're gonna I think they're going to
look like this yeah and you know well I
think that's and that's for me that's
when they get more viable for me right
yeah I don't I can't fathom relaxing
while I have this giant thing hanging
off my face and maybe smacked my wife
you know yeah but yeah you put some me
nice and beautifully sleek like this on
and that's got me again oh yeah Warren
one of the things I want to ask you is
you've been outspoken about the triple a
model and also an advocate a great
advocate of the independent model and
also the digital distribution model and
all these kinds of things the middle
ground is totally fallen away in games
as we've seen with you know THQ is
always emblematic of that right the fall
of THQ when you said right yep how do
you feel things are shaping up now
because we were talking about the 100
million dollar triple A's and we're
talking about this you know cup head or
something like that that's made on a
shoestring budget maybe less than a
million dollars yeah how are they
shaping up in your mind are things are
things stable in the games industry
right now
I don't think there's any stability
quite frankly when I look forward at
product i mean we started a business
once going digital that relies on these
networks we rely on an indie premium
pricing but there's more and more
services that are going to be running
you know ten cents per minute that they
want to pay you instead of soup so
there's free to play companies that are
now building titles that are I was just
talking to brand new titles you've never
heard of the IP they're going to spend
30 40 million on that for mobile right
so it used to be three hundred thousand
dollars if it's stuck now you're going
to be competing against 35 million
dollar titles that are free right so
free is going to become so like rich
backed by the big boys how you going to
get in there with something that
competes with that when you're a little
guy it's going to be difficult but
here's the thing is if it were only
those big titles we would never see an
old man sky right right if it were only
that so let's look around and go which
of these titles came out of Indy groups
that never would have had the support
that wouldn't have been here seven years
ago they're actually increasingly big
what's everyone most excited about when
we talk about AR minecraft something
that no title no publisher really would
have backed no one would really believe
then he goes out there kicks ass so
drastically then everyone's trying to
you know take him on the date right
everyone's trying to get into his
business now well that wasn't possible
before these trends either so we live in
a cheap world very a very small
percentage of the audience believes i
like that i should support it if we look
at when something's free on steam or
something or trends of PS plus offerings
free some of the comments you see people
ago why would ever buy an indie title
again i'm just going to wait till it's
free right and you're like well the
reason is because you might want is that
developer to build more in the title
right uh you you how you vote yeah we've
been conditioned in America to think
you're smart if you're shaving the best
deal and if you're buying at walmart
right well that's not clearly the
definition of smart the real value the
real power of the individuals and how
they spend their money who they choose
to support and who they don't the beauty
today is if someone buys our title they
can know a lot of that money 70
that money's coming back to us and we're
going to build more games with it and
it's not going to shareholders in wall
street they're gonna you know do some
some hedge fund some right all right
spread across this is like authentic
relationships to customers what's hard
to tell is how where is the customer
base going to continue to believe in
supporting the products as opposed to
just wanting the free trend right now
personally I don't play free to play
games it's not because I have something
against them but as a player I find it
offensive because I understand the
psychological design of how they're
trying to figure out my impulse buy
pattern and then charge me at every time
it starts getting good right and I just
I just find that offensive yeah I find
certain TV shows offensive doesn't mean
I shouldn't be there right but so how do
we compete with that in the future how
do you do it when you have
character-driven story games they're
going to be more isolated experience
well a huge boost of faith in that to me
happened on a monday i believe was the
sony press conference right monday
morning yes one day a monday evening and
in that last guardian right crowd went
wild for it right so two characters on
the screen it's a beautiful environment
it's a slow experience it's an old
platforming model done in a new way but
that crowd loved it so tonight I was one
of my favorite things in the shelter and
when I see that and as the audience
starts on so that's not going to have I
don't think that's going to have like
traditionally it's not going to have the
billion-dollar audience but it's going
to have a smaller audience that's really
passionate about it that's probably
going to wind up with tattoos you know
because they're that passion yeah yes
definitely was so in that same
conference though and it's kind of going
back to supporting people like one to
one with the audience we also saw
Shenmue come out and and announced a
Kickstarter which I think God funded
that's a immediately basically I wonder
if I have that I have it on my on my
browser in the phone I keep updating
every like two hours to see where
they're at do you know where they're I
don't know whether I know I can find out
yeah chicken good job that I mean that's
a fascinating concept right because
that's you're talking about a huge
company coming out and saying hey come
support this title now I have to imagine
I don't know the specifics yeah and you
can buy speak more to this but i'm
guessing sony's actually backing them as
well to a certain degree i don't know
you don't know i don't know is it
backing in spirit and saying we believe
in this and we hope you do too and
you supported they still retain their
autonomy or is it get more complicated
because now the crowd fund was given to
you know it's split I don't know right
the logistics are but I do know that uh
gave raged well right now uh 3.2 million
ok so the shot past there two million
mark pretty quickly yeah it is really
well on the time we've been sleeping I
think it's two days yeah is some people
were really offended by that Kickstarter
being on Sony stage and I was like I
totally understand that I think it is
weird but I was I was going to use like
Sony push sports friends Kickstarter
amplitude is an IP so many owns and they
allowed that to be kick-started so I'm
like this is a new no one's been paying
attention when they've been doing it
before and I think this is the first one
where they were like what are you guys
doing it I'm I've been saying this for a
couple years they've been doing this for
a while so I didn't you know I said so
kick crowd funding for games he's really
pre-sales right that's really what it is
ya think of that I mean we've been kind
of crowd funding but backwards we sell
them a product we get the sale and then
we reinvest in product but we're getting
the money after we built the product
crowd funding is we get the money before
we built the product but it's really a
pre-sale now what is happening is the
SEC in the United States just change the
law are you familiar with this though
now crowdfunding can actually owned
securities in the company oh and
actually own shares and equity that
isn't that something that's a game
changer right there this is a big Liam
lots of big questions tell me that we
have to wrap up because you and I have
to go over to you too oh do you want me
to go over to youtube and you can stay
for a few more minutes or what do you
want what time is it it's I know we have
to wrap a bit early cuz we have to run
over to the finish your thought or in
please sorry okay so we got we got a
game-changing crowdfunding model coming
to which allows them to actually own
equity in the company comes with lots of
complications but the law is just passed
enabling it and as people some big
people going to be announcing some big
platforms that they're creating to to
let this happen how's the crab going to
react order some of them going to have
the reaction you mentioned or are we
going to see that when I think a lot of
it comes back to is the power going back
to the creator and I mean that's like
actually that has to be right because
what you hope so right woman hope I mean
if yeah if you're telling me that all
these people are supporting
game like Shenmue for no return on their
investment and then suddenly you say hey
if you do this I'll give you know you
might get a five percent or two percent
or three and half percent which roi I'm
in you I'm going to do it anyway right I
find it i funded super troopers the
other day that was the last thing I find
it I want to see the movie be made yeah
you tell him you're going to give me a
check for five bucks after that don't so
Ennis yeah exactly so if you know so
that's like tiering what that money
equals for you but is is a trend where
big big corporate brands can lend their
spirit their support in spirit we would
like to see these creators do more
doesn't necessarily fit our model but if
it fits her for you the audience and you
want it will will grease the skids and
help get out there is that the message
is being sent I'm not exactly sure but I
think if you have big powers that can
provide visibility and that shines light
on something like Shenmue they just hit
their mark they just exceeded their mark
right I think they still you know the
reason they're doing is because they're
doing it on their own if they got
support like when Sony asked us to be up
on the indie showcase stage there was
you know it wasn't a financial
transaction wasn't asked lose
exclusivity deal I mean they did say
look if we're gonna highlight you give
us 30 days and you're like we're not
going to be able to deliver other skews
within 30 days anyway right you know so
why wouldn't we want your support and we
do get that support well damn you know
we rely on that will release a product
on the apple store now if we have to
rely on our own advertising and
marketing we're not going anywhere so we
gotta deliver a good enough product that
they want to promote it right but they
don't own it they're just going to take
a slice of their store we're so small it
doesn't really matter but they'll
highlight something as special to the
audience so I think it's all a lot of
fuzzy space huge possibilities I mean
look at you guys patreon you know that
wasn't around a couple years ago right
changes everything now you're on your
own now but now look where you're
sitting out the kingdom yes yes and here
in your throne you're being supported by
a big brand but you're still doing
patreon right what does that mean is
that does that mean you're not in the
true spirit no I know you guys I know
you're still shooting out of the house I
know you still got that true spirit but
if you get this type of brand support
then you're going to have a wider a
wider exposure and that's only going to
help independent so the key is can you
keep that independent and get that
exposure if you can
than in 10 years from here all the
biggest titles they're going to be up
coming out of the indie space probably
crowdfunded probably yep you know indie
guys know man skies things like that
getting out there and then getting the
big support hopefully holding onto their
autonomy unless they cash out and if the
cash out minecraft good for them right
coach for you man it's always awesome
talking to man I'm sorry we have to wrap
up thank you got it out it's great to be
here like I'm even interviewing what I
want done it you have like come back
bicycling back with more of the podcast
together yeah it was amazing spending
the day thanks so much for joining us
yeah let's do it everyone else out there
stay tuned Khloe's coming up next with a
special surprise for you we'll be right
back